I hope that helps you understand what
did it come to that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
but is Harry's post royal life turning
out to be as peaceful as he had hoped
the 35 year olds friend and renowned
conservationist dr. Jane Goodall reveals
in a new interview that things haven't
been easy The Guardian reports that
Goodall recently told the Radio Times
that she spoken to Harry adding quote I
don't know how his career is going to
map out but yes I've been in touch
though I think he's finding life a bit
challenging just now the Duke of Sussex
recently relocated to Los Angeles with
his wife Megan Markel and their 11
month-old son Archie after making their
royal exit in March they're renting an
ocean wherever they are they're
obviously keeping a low profile like
everyone else they have been in
quarantine due to the corona virus
outbreak a royal source tells ET that
things have been stressful for Harry
since moving to Southern California his
father Prince Charles tested positive
for Kovan 19 last month though is now
thankfully in good health our source
adds quote we know he's been concerned
for family in the UK naturally but he
wants to do what he thinks is best for
his own family I always take my family I
know I have a family to protect
and according to Goodall Harry actually
hinted at a royal exit last fall
[Applause]
Perry attended the famed primatologists
Roots & Shoots global leadership
gathering last July it was at this event
that he insisted he'd have two children
max to minimize his impact on the planet
the Duke also interviewed Goodall for
the September issue of British Vogue the
one Megan guest edited and I didn't know
if anyone has ever done it before
according to what Goodall previously
told Daily Mail's weekend magazine Harry
suggested the couple's plans during this
interview the 86 year old told the
outlet she got to hold Archie and made
him do the Queen's wave telling Harry
quote I suppose he'll have to learn this
but Goodall says Harry quickly responded
quote no he's not growing up like that
[Music]
Archy turns one on May 6
he's burbling and and and sort of
desperate to to talk but certainly
already mastered cruising and is well on
his way to walking he may even be
walking already but I was told very cute
very very happy and very confident
little boy
[Music]